la candidatura ibérica para albergar el
mundial de fútbol 2030 ahora es europea
así lo afirmó el presidente de la Real
federación española de fútbol Luis
rubiales en la sede de la UEFA en Neón
Suiza lo dijo durante la conferencia de
prensa de presentación de España y
Portugal como potenciales sedes del
Campeonato a la que ahora se suma
Ucrania un día para la felicidad según
el español quien aseguró que esta es la
candidatura ganadora y de la paz la
incorporación de Ucrania añadiría dos
sedes en kiev idóneas a las 11 de España
y a las 3 portuguesas preguntados por
las condiciones de seguridad tanto el
presidente de la federación ucraniana
como el de la portuguesa aseguraron que
es la prioridad y que esperan que en
ocho años la guerra haya terminado y se
cumplan las condiciones de seguridad
para llevar a cabo el evento muchos
creen que la participación de Ucrania es
el ingrediente clave para que esta
candidatura salga adelante sin embargo
la copa del mundo 2030 es la del
centenario y este dato podría ser el que
inclina la balanza hacia la candidatura
America con Uruguay a la cabeza y
posiblemente Argentina Paraguay y chile
fue precisamente en tierras uruguayas
donde se disputó la primera edición del
mundial de fútbol y según el presidente
de conmebol la Copa tiene que regresar a
casa para sus 100 años las dudas sobre
si se repetirá un mundial en suelo
americano porque recordemos que en 2026
serán México Canadá y Estados Unidos los
anfitriones o si será en suelo europeo
se despejarán previsiblemente en mayo de